violent clashes drove these students to
take cover
now trapped for days
one of them shows us their shelter in a
faculty basement they have limited
supplies and are unable to leave for
help
a student has been killed and we can't
move his corpse another student has a
serious injury the situation is dire and
we need intervention as soon as possible
and as he calls for help gunfire rings
out
all across the capital confrontations
between the Army and paramilitary Rapid
support forces have engulfed the city in
Smoke the two strongest armed forces in
the country head to head but days on
it's still unclear what gains have been
made
as the battle for power spreads from the
streets to social media
this state broadcast shared to the Armed
Forces Facebook has soldiers yelling
where are the rapid support forces to
the sound of Victorious music
videos uploaded by the rapid support
forces showed their officer claiming
control of the state broadcasters
officers and the state airport in the
northern city of meadowy
we got on a call with the Army Chief and
de facto head of state
okay the head of the Army is currently
calling us back
will you go to the negotiation table for
the stability of the country
it's possible he says if negotiations
will restore the country on our fare
then it's possible I ask him about the
presidents who have offered to fly in to
mediate talks he says the current
climate of clashes isn't suitable to
welcome them
please for peace continue to pour in
from across the International Community
the immediate
future lies in the hands of the generals
who are engaged in this fight and we
call upon them to
put peace first
to bring an end to the fighting
with a closed Aerospace
internationally-led peace talks are
currently off the table
for now millions are trapped waiting for
a resolution that feels more distant
than ever
Sky News